they appear on some of the photos like
any other loving couple documenting a
life of luxury lived together a ski trip
a tight embrace even a visit it seems to
the queen's balmoral estate pictured in
the same spot where her majesty has been
photographed
but these pictures including those taken
aboard jeffrey epstein's private plane
are now evidence in a sex trafficking
trial which could see glenn maxwell
spend the rest of her life in prison the
prosecution argues they show not only
romantic partners but partners in crime
they were found on cds and hard drives
seized during a police raid of epstein's
new york mansion stored inside wardrobes
and a safe also found was this advert
apparently created by maxwell
advertising for a massage therapist much
of epstein's abusing is said to have
centered around massages
the prosecution's case is that glenn
maxwell and jeffrey epstein's lives were
very much intertwined that while they
may have started out as boyfriend and
girlfriend glenn maxwell soon became
much more than that one witness
described her as
in command
david rogers a former pilot for epstein
was asked where ms maxwell sat in the
hierarchy she would be number two he
said below whom the prosecutor asked he
responded jeffrey epstein
the prosecution is expected to rest its
case tomorrow having perhaps saved their
strongest witness for last then it will
be the defense's turn to argue that
glenn maxwell is not the handmaiden to
sex abuse she's being portrayed as